I potted the mics up before I had to are
you tired of that you don't like to be
talked about be pining the mics up yeah
I don't need [ __ ] oh let's we got Kim
no I did
I'm not Hans yeah I'm on three I'm sorry
I parted most of the muscle you know now
hot it up Jim because that's where I
john lipsky was gonna sit lick cow thank
you that's not let's go it expelled the
scouts but it's let's go let's go
okay you call him let's go all right
let's bring him in I wonder if he heard
about this Nicki Minaj Remy Ma B he was
talking about on another show he was
right yeah I wouldn't heard about the
Oscars gasps let's ask him well right
when he nominated if we say to him did
you did you hear about what happened at
the Oscars last night like just a couple
of [ __ ] I want to see how he handles
that oh yeah that was terrible I'm gonna
ask him people been saying that Nicki
Minaj got bodied by Remy Ma do you find
so all right thank you so much you know
like yeah if y'all hear all right all
right good job let's go in here but the
bodies were killed that's what they're
saying I didn't know a body event who
can I thought it meant like body slam
Floyd in the [ __ ] world and me right he
got killed right oh crap right bite with
through song you helped through a song I
did I wouldn't describe that world that
way I'd probably get yelled at that was
my description I would've been in big
trouble
guys it was like a bud a Roberta Flack
song killing me killing them softly
through song yes yes remember we met
Roberta Flack I do remember she wanted
to [ __ ] me so badly but I could just
tell what you want the [ __ ] man why when
you kids because the way you lingered
waiting for a photo is she was having a
conversation with other people no sorry
I [ __ ] helped her through the crowd
and her feet were all right here he
comes
ah hello John Michelle welcome I'll take
it down yeah yes
make yourself comfortable that's a
tremendous jacket you have on thank you
yes right clown costume
nice is that Gucci we're talking it's uh
Miyake okay see it Miyake a good brand
I'm not familiar yeah
ask my wife she's I'll she checks it out
yeah yeah what's good another Union iake
it's Japanese II owe you sir Miyake is a
cologne I have that yeah I do have it
but I didn't ever notice Miyake I have
this eval key okay there you go
welcome to
hey how are you what happened last night
I saw it I not only thought but I read I
I when I saw it twice and three times
while you watched it again and again
yeah it was fascinating yeah trying to
figure out exactly who knew what when
nice but you've been up there not even
one you've nominated for an Oscar you've
won tons of awards oh yeah so you know
what that feeling is right to be onstage
and have the trophy and give the speech
yeah so how much do you suppose that
would feel if somebody was like Oh John
before you finish I can't even imagine
like scrambled brains yeah it's hard
enough it winning you know but winning
and then losing did you like the one guy
who made the speech anyway even though
he knew they lost he's excited but I
think you you don't know what you're
doing up there I just won a SAG Award
and completely forgot the name of like
the costume designer of the crown and
just stood there like a deer in the
headlights
seemed to me about 15 seconds it was
about a second and a half so have you
written up speeches that you didn't get
to make because people pull out a
prepared speech yeah so everyone who
loses has a speech written up so you've
written up a few that you didn't make
yeah I sure and and I've thought of
different speeches that I've immediately
scrapped just before going up to the
podium
why just grab them just because I
thought of something funnier those are
the those are the great ones but you
know it's a it's a it's a funny business
something happens to your entire body
but that would that's why I rebroadcast
that moment from last night
it's just wondering what was going
through poor Warren Beatty's head yeah
we saw one trying to talk a couple of
times and then we thought like wait the
way they kind of just jumped in front of
him that was not have happened in 1976
if Warren Beatty wanted to talk he was
right but also he you know he the first
time through I thought oh come on Warren
don't do a number this is not right you
know it's not funny don't you're
extending it Tom but then rebroadcasting
it thinking he knew something was wrong
do you like the way he points out that
he just threw it
Faye Dunaway all right and sure enough
she's now in the doghouse but what would
you do in that situation would you see
you see Emma Stone's name would you read
it or would you go there's a mistake and
go look I hate to do this but I think
there's a mistake well I you can
speculate I think I would say yes
something's wrong here because something
clearly was wrong but the other thing
was lala land was such an odds-on
favorite if everything had gone smoothly
and just as it should
moonlight would have been an astonishing
upset and the place would have gone nuts
yeah it was like we said before and
crash one a few years ago instead of I
guess back mountain cooler shock just
but now that huge corporate gasp but
that shot goes away because like you
watch it and then people are shocked
that moon like one but you're watching
them and no they're shocked because
they're watching just shows guys lose
right in front of my nose yeah amazing
just amazed
I thought the one guy handled it well
the one producer who has made the
announcement he behaved like a producer
when he was catch that thing all of you
he's not a real Oh Paul yeah it was
great
poor one don't bad form yeah except the
other guy the other producer who's like
off camera and he goes yeah I don't know
they read it wrong so annoying oh dear
yeah by the way and you're promoting the
name of your show is trial and error
it's a kind of a mockumentary comedy
premieres Tuesday March 14th ten o'clock
on NBC and I thought it was a drama
until I washed it and I'm like I miss
Pryor courtroom drama and you play a guy
named Larry Henderson accused of killing
his wife yes and for the whole extent 13
episodes of the season I have to sustain
the possibility that I either did or did
not right and it's amazing because it's
hilarious show but it also works as a
suspenseful whodunit procedural yeah
even though it's completely crazy would
you call it I would call almost
ludicrous and a Monty Python type of way
is it's out there it's the craziest
thing I've done since third Rock from
the Sun it is it's very absurd it's like
absurdist yes yeah but and don't you
find yourself trying to figure out like
I was watching it and going like but I
think that there's a cool over
there are clues everywhere and red
herrings and misleads it's just great
it's so ingenious the way these are
going to be the creators Jeff Ostroff
and Matt Miller it's an interesting
combination as a straw is purely a
comedy writer and Matt Miller is this
procedural guy you know in fact he's
also the showrunner on Lethal Weapon
simultaneous with trial and error so it
has both things going
yet each episode ends with a cliffhanger
that may yeah dying to know what happens
next
even though it's all completely
outrageous and ridiculous it is very
silly but it was well-written and I
really only gave a three episode so I
got through the first three episodes and
I'm like you I first kind of reminded me
of a follow-up from the crown like it's
pretty similar you know the character is
so alive he's basically like you're
watching it and it would appear that
he's very very guilty of murdering is
his wife but he's like almost too stupid
relative healthy you know it's not
exactly stupid it's just he's like a man
with absolutely no sense of proportion
perspective or priorities yeah as far as
he's concerned his wife dying in front
of him and the Cable Guy not showing up
or matters of equal urgency yeah yes he
really looks guilty and then like I
don't know if he's guilty but they're
like yeah yes yell there's a few reveals
that are very very funny yeah so and and
this wonderful cast I have to name them
all they're so great Nick be Agosto he
plays the one same character this New
York lawyer who has come down to help to
defend me yes and Sherri Shepherd and
Steve Boyer and Krista Roger Shepard is
great by the way she's hilarious
absolutely and who knew who knew she was
such a funny you just look at her a new
lab yeah she's great she just stand up
so I mean I didn't know she was a
comedic actress really good rate in such
a doll and Jayma Mays from Glee and Bob
Gunton and I even have a single scene
late in the series with French Stewart
from third Rock oh wow okay we sort of
revive the old third Rock
energy and he's a witness coach I would
imagine that the character's name being
Larry Henderson is not a apparent
accident apparently they when they were
trying to seduce me into doing this they
made they named the character Larry
Anderson I think that was kind of get
chillin and I'm easily seduced yeah it
worked well yeah it was good you find it
like after you do something like the
crown like especially when it gets the
critical acclaim that it has is just
again as successful as a show can be
like do you want to kind of just do a
victory lap and go I'm John Lithgow from
the crown everybody you know or is it
let's go right back into work let's find
the next you know actors always have
that lurking insecurity what's next will
will I ever work again
it it never leaves you basically you're
always while you're doing a job that's
the best time to get another job I
actually spoke to these guys on the
phone I from London they were in LA Matt
and Jeff they pitched the show to me in
the course of about 40 minutes on the
telephone after I just spent a 14-hour
days shooting on the crown and here I
was listening to these wacko Hollywood
comedy writers pitched this oddball
series to me it was on the basis of that
that I decided to do it how far does
have to go before he gets to you on the
phone while you're on the set like how
many people do they have to go through
before they finally put on the doors and
the first I heard about it was from my
agent but it all happened very fast I
had to decide right away because it was
pilot season and these things go
lightning quick but it's you know they
sold the premise it was to me they made
me laugh hard just talking about it and
then I met them for the first time when
I finally got home to LA and when you're
shooting the crown you essentially you
think you were so great in that it was
such a good good show that you were
intimidated to play such an important
British character oh yeah sure I mean I
was excited and scared in equal measure
but ah far more excited that and I had a
lot of faith in all
the circumstances Peter Morgan the
writer Stephen Daldry the director these
guys if they wanted me I guess they knew
what they were doing
now would you you did a lot of a
research visit so you a method guy so
you acted like Churchill off camera no
okay I just what I put on my fat food
and I was Churchill I did do a huge
amount of research I don't think I've
ever worked quite so much just delved
into a character's history including his
young years I've but mainly I just found
the man so fascinating a lot of people
have had that experience they just begin
to learn about Churchill and they can't
get enough he's so intriguing and such a
significant character in the 20th
century I found it kind of heartbreaking
and explained so much it he had such an
unhappy childhood he was such a
neglected and lonely and needy kid and
an a screw-up you know he failed at
everything he ended up turning toward
the military like und vampa Sandhurst
because he knew it was like being sent
to military school as a high schooler
and just you you see his entire life in
terms of his insecurities and his
efforts to overcompensate he turned
himself into this extraordinarily
powerful and decisive man and I think as
with any character his very young years
in inform is very old years did you like
the royal family more or less it were
less after watch after doing this show
cuz I was the Queen kind of like just
the pomp and sir it annoyed me after a
while like not to show but the idea of
what the Queen does I'm like no because
it's real life you mean because we
actually have to go through all the pomp
and circumstance in the way she kind of
you know [ __ ] Margaret by not backing
her under marriage it really annoyed me
we all accept that it's real it's a real
family with real family issues it's just
that they are at the same time the most
public and the most private family in
the world it's almost a matter of policy
that they never express an emotion
publicly and I've only one of the Royals
that I've met is Charles and Camilla on
three occasions actually and the
conversation with these people can
imagine is so perfectly but now they you
know they have to they have to speak
small talk as if it's poetry you know
it's just so totally colorless an adult
well you talk about oh you know they
well in each case it was after a
performance so they found something to
talk about about the perform with a teen
you perform yeah oh yeah on a TD or a
life let's see it live in each case I
was I performed at a gala actually it
was two galas one at the Royal
Shakespeare Company last spring and you
know they're very charged is extremely
charming but just but now you don't
touch anything that could possibly be
considered controversial that's right
you guys you know because I get like
these are potentially some of the more
interesting people that you could have a
conversation way you're kind of a little
bit elated by the ceremony of it I mean
you're you're meeting a royal but that's
what the whole series is all about is
it's sort of a rumination on the
monarchy and the reason for the monarchy
or the or the opposite you know whether
it makes any sense to have a
constitutional but how about a secret
society background did you have the leg
dwell into that or you're already
internet well I
I mean Churchill had been everything you
know by the time he was an old man it's
the story of him as being the prime
minister for the second time becoming
the prime minister at age 75 which is
too old yeah in that position and yet
hanging on to it for dear life in a very
very crafty and expert way political way
you know that that's that's what I found
most intriguing he had this sense that
he was the only person who could could
solve the world's problems literally
thought it has to be me and Stalin and
Eisenhower we're the only ones who can
guarantee world peace so I have to hang
in there
as he approached eighty years old I mean
that's quite a story
hey after all the world according to
GARP - like it amaze you now you play
this trans character and now it's a
everyone is talking about it but you did
that pride before anybody yeah that was
1982 or something a remarkable film that
was so far ahead of its time it's it's
true it's now I'm like the old founder
or something did you say close to Robin
after that I'm not close I saw him
occasionally we we worked very closely
together during that film under these
rather strange circumstances I was
always dressed as a woman
and it was a it was a period of his life
where he was had a serious love affair
with cocaine oh so it was uh it was
difficult would it be hard on a set like
sometimes an honor oh no no no it's just
that he he would I found out years later
that he he was we were working out on
fishers island way off off New London
Connecticut
for like three or four weeks and he was
spending his nights in New York at clubs
and who knew that he was a man who was
not sleeping and yet while he was
working he was completely absorbed very
reliable but it made him Moody it made
him distant you know hear that was oh
gosh almost 30 years ago and yet you
could see the beginnings of that the
things that led him to the mood of the
depression and yeah yeah that's at end
your are you doing are you doing daddy's
home - with Mel Gibson yes have you
worked as Mel Gibson before no I've
never met Mel and he strides there
believing in answering
she messaged we've we have exchanged the
mails and I start working with them next
week yeah I'm watching to see how that
turns out because I mean scandals aside
Mel Gibson strikes me is one of the more
hardcore you know acting like just
everything he does it seems that just
dives into his well intense intense well
the premise of daddy's home to is you
know the first one was Will Ferrell and
Mark Wahlberg their two fathers enter
the picture right so Mel Gibson as
Mark's father and I as Will's father
strikes me as perfect casting as a kid
could it be hilarious and like to see
him making a comeback kind of people you
know when you screw up in Hollywood you
take a little time off they're pissed at
you and all of a sudden like I write you
know he is absolutely perfect casting I
think it's going to be hillarious I go
up there next week for the first time to
mix it up with those guys and then so
that and then have you are you doing
pitch perfect 3 is that Alright
I'm rebel Wilson's father and I think
I'm movie comedy for a sequel dad it is
a franchise it's nice right it's a nice
thing to be known for
yeah but rebel is absolutely great I
said having a wonderful time with her I
go back to finish that film doing so
many things at the same time I know
insane that's what I have and Here I am
promoting trial and error right so I
said but is that something as I get like
you said you're doing pitch perfect 3
now you're getting ready to do daddy's
home brew everybody's talking about the
crown because it's streaming and you're
trying to promote this yeah trial and
error that you obviously filmed a long
time we didn't we finished that in
mid-december right so so is it kind of
like now you're talking about this stuff
that is like well I'm trying to keep my
thoughts straight yeah let's put it that
way I know I mean they're all incredibly
fun I the great thing is to do this kind
of very dignified and fine and worthy
series the crown and then immediately
follow it up with this hat-trick of a
complete lunatic it
having a wonderful time it's got it
keeps you from getting boring
yeah I don't want to bore myself you
know tight little own audience right no
no and there were all very different
characters as rebel Wilson's father I'm
sort of this scuzzy Australian conman so
she's been coaching me on my Australian
accent do you think I sing in I dance
you do we danced the tango in a casino
hey do they have to teach you are you
actually a good dancer as a good as a
dancer I'm a very good actor that's how
I you know okay but no they they make
you look good God knows there's a
fabulous choreographer who just put me
through my paces it was exhausting I
have to say that I'm a little old for
this
it is a rumor a good rapper - oh I've
done that up here on this floor what
they wrote a rap song for me I think for
for the crown when I came to talk about
that yeah yeah Finnick yeah he's pitiful
this you know man don't don't even ask
me I'm going to embarrass both of us
it's a dangerous game I'm sure Remy Ma
Nicki Minaj where you can always or
gradually so yeah you don't want to be a
clown when you're fighting for the crown
exactly right listen to you yeah that's
really great huh yeah I'm really good
good okay oh that's [ __ ] good it was
very much I was incredible now you also
uh you're getting awarded a Harville you
all harvard arts medal in April and you
went to Harvard made a commencement
speech how nerve-wracking is that to
have to talk to a bunch of Harvard
graduates
oh that was great I was 2005 yeah I was
they I've been quite involved at Harvard
since going there in fact I this medal
that they're presenting me with I
actually established that medal 25 years
ago all these years I've recused myself
it's for people who went to Harvard but
then went into the creative arts so over
the years Jack Lemmon and Bonnie Raitt
and yo-yo ma all these Matt Damon and
Tommy Lee Jones they've all gotten it
and they finally at the 25th anniversary
they've insisted on giving it to me wait
till they got to give it to you before
and you said no I won't yeah yeah I said
I said no no I I created this thing I
shouldn't take it home that's what we're
different I would want the first year
second [ __ ] award the president of
Harvard called me and said no no you
have to accept it this year so I did
Cesar how do you feel about a kid I mean
you've done so much stuff that obviously
people remember different things but I
think there's something about like and
this goes back to what we took trial and
error there's something about a network
sitcom does obviously as you know just
six of people like I was talking to my
wife yesterday about you coming in she
literally just finished the crown and
she watched it and she loved it and
she's obsessed with it by blah and as I
guess he's coming in tomorrow and she's
eyes like John Lithgow and she's like
really and I'm like yeah from the crown
and she goes third but in all this work
she's everything and it shows my people
right back to third Rock well you know I
I just love shifting gears it's a it's
what I got into it for I you know I grew
up in the theater family and my father
ran Shakespeare Festival's out in Ohio
one of them the Great Lakes Theater
Festival and Cleveland's still going on
and I acted in the plays even as a kid
even as a little boy and by the time I
was a teenager I was playing small parts
Shakespeare wrote for a theatre company
and he wrote and his plays played in
repertory he wrote Hamlet but he also
wrote comedy of errors he wrote my best
and he wrote Merry Wives of Windsor you
know he wrote tragedies and loopy
comedies and and history plays and you
play a different part in a different
kind of play every night
well that's can I eat without even
calculating it that's kind of how I run
my acting career I always love to do
something as different as possible from
what I just did and you can't always do
that but when it when it happens it's
exciting you know and you don't mind
getting like like attached
like certain people will just attach you
to this thing like in their memory well
you know you have to kind of defy that
you have to sort of work hard to never
allow yourself to be pigeonholed the
closest I ever came to it was six years
on third Rock sure but that was that in
itself was playing a different that was
an alien who's trying to figure out how
to behave like a human being right
that's like an actor playing lots of
different parts right right and also
you're promoting just people wrapping up
very soon as our show end trial and
error and it's on NBC March 14th at
10:00 p.m. and it is a rich absurd
comedy and we've seen the first three
episodes very very unique and funny and
it's really original and you're great at
effective as the great thing is then NBC
is doing two shows back to back every
Tuesday night for seven weeks so uh
that's why it's almost like a Netflix
series NBC is getting very creative with
its programming as always the intention
is to really hook people and that's like
is making people not want to wait from
week right that's right very difficult
you want to see it and you want to see
what's happening next and who could you
like the show because what happens to
his characters wife is something that
you've wanted to happen to your ex-wife
for a long time we're still doing
nothing but we didn't go there
accidentally go to a window [ __ ] that
wicked cruciate got his wife a pair of
Yeezys ever very very popular sneakers
and then enough and then announced on
the air her jogging route in case
anybody wanted to steal it easy while
killer for the city yeah there's that
true or fault hey fill out this okay
I'm suddenly seeing this show in a very
well you're all you're great and uh
thanks for coming in and the appreciate
everybody listening we'll be here
tomorrow yes and will further discuss
these shitty photos of us and our wife
Shelley uh you want to hear how an
eight-by-ten yeah just the most
pixelated awful I mean usually I got to
sign this form he thought he was on a
professional show and then he saw these
guys yeah he's getting Ranger a
boyfriend
yeah he's humiliated and so alone
you should see some of the pictures they
asked me to autograph outside the door
of this very building q alright guys
thank you very much and yeah see them
off thank you guys great to talk to you
guys